welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Apocalypse Now my my film
is not a movie my film is not uh about
Vietnam it is Vietnam was
crazy
the
horror often labeled as one of the best
movies of all time I've been waiting to
break down this movie for a while now
but in all honesty I didn't feel like I
was up to the task however after pouring
through all the making of material every
version of the film and numerous
interviews I finally feel as ready as
I'll be to tackle this
Behemoth The Views the views it was an
onslaught to be honest and I had to dig
deep into my own Heart of Darkness in
order to unearth all the hin layers
within the movie Apocalypse Now is one
of those films that really made America
hold up a mirror to itself and question
all things that went on during the
conflict it of course went on to inspire
several films that followed it with this
really Paving the way for the Vietnam
War epics that would have come in the
following decades highly influential it
had Martin Sheen's Willard narrating and
delving deeper into what I've always
deemed as Dante's Inferno whilst he
questioned the insanity of War this to
me is about a man traveling through the
circles of hell on an inward Journey
which showed Humanity returning to a
primal
state
that is the apocalypse the downfall of
civilization which made us as few as
question the toll that war can have in
one's Soul the Insite this would later
be picked up and inspired into films
like platoon which even took marttin and
Charlie and had him the rating over it
too if you've seen Hot Shots po the pair
literally have two bits of narration
overriding the other I'm so tired we get
up at at first I thought they'd handed
me the wrong dossier I couldn't believe
they wanted this man dead third
generation West Point top of his class
Korea Airborne about a thousand
decorations etc
etc i l you in Wall
Street now platoon's rider Oliver Stone
admitted that he took a lot from this
with him even Penning his script to The
End by The Doors Stone actually fought
in the conflict but it's difficult to
argue that cop didn't create his
authentic a feeling film which has
completely altered how we view the war
this is the
[Music]
beautiful
friend now to me this movie very much
Creed the soundtrack for Vietnam and
also the town and atmosphere that we
have when we look back at it those
single guitar strings the fire washing
the trees and the smell of night Palm in
the morning all of it stems directly
from this film now growing up this was
one of the films that I hadn't actually
seen But I pretty much knew all the
references and nods before actually
watching it like The Shining The
Simpsons had done so many parodies of it
I felt like I'd seen the movie before
ever putting it on it's it's difficult
to think of a time where I wasn't aware
of this film but watching it is a whole
other matter for this video I'm going to
be covering the Final Cut version as
that's well the final final final Final
Cut of the movie but I will touch you on
the Redux which I always thought was
redo but no according to the creative
team that's how it's pronounced directed
by Francis Ford C the film was its own
war zone both on and off camera with
there being several setbacks that the
creative team had to go through just
making this movie is almost as legendary
as what we see the people on screen
diving into with the making of
chronicling how Bleak the production was
this itself is documented in hearts of
Darkness a filmmaker's apocalypse which
in itself could be adapted into its own
film a 90-minute documentary is probably
as close as we'll get though and it
outlines some of the things Copa had to
go through in order to get this film
finally made now that title hearts of
darkness is actually a nod of the book
by Joseph Conrad that the whole movie is
based on titled hot of darkness is 1899
Nolla took place on the Congo River with
it documenting the journey to find a
rich Ivory Trader stationed in the
jungle in the 30s oron Wells was
planning on adapting it with a film
almost going into production until the
studio pulled the plug that was because
of the cost and Wells then made Citizen
Kane instead and it was years later that
cobbler ended up trying again this
adaptation of course shifted things to
Vietnam and many people mistakenly
believe that's where the book took place
Marlon brano's Curt appears in the
source material too though they did
change some things up due to some let's
say some choices by the actor Copler
ended up shopping around the idea for
the film but due the tensions over the
war at the time absolutely no Studio
wanted it soldiers were getting spat on
the country was still reeling from the
loss and all in all it was something
Hollywood didn't want to touch CPL then
of course went on to make the Godfather
part one and two which made him a
multi-millionaire and after launching
his own Studio they themselves put it
into production now originally it was
co-written by cop Michael her and John
milus with the idea being that George
Lucas would direct however after he
dropped out Copler took over with him
being heavily influenced by wner
herzog's wrath of God Lucas and Copa go
way back though and the latter left a
little tribute to his pal in the form of
Harrison Ford's character Ford of course
stared in both Lucas's American Graffiti
and a little known picture called Star
Wars with them calling his character
Colonel G Lucas General corman's also a
nod to Roger Corman Whose advice for
shooting in the jungle was don't James
KH was also originally lined up to play
Lucas but he wanted too much money for
what he considered a small role so they
cast forward who was relatively unknown
but he of course blew up making it a
lucky get for the film even though it's
a small role deep down I feel like Lucas
may have dodged to Bullet as he was
completely exhausted during the creation
of Star Wars and this is why he didn't
end up directing Empire or return this
movie probably would have made it so we
never got one of the biggest franchises
of all time and in the end I feel things
worked out even if they weren't that
Pleasant at the time now originally it
was said to be a 6 week shoot but this
ballooned up to 16 months in total they
shot for 238 days but amongst this were
a number of setbacks and shutdowns on
the production coming off the back of
the Godfathers there was also a lot of
pressure on Copa to make a massive
follower but the Press at the time they
often reported on the disaster that it
was behind the scenes CA self financed a
lot of the film and basically needed it
to be a success for his career and his
bank account screening of his hands he
won the Palm de but this came off the
back of two years in the editing room in
the end he took out a lot of the weirder
parts of the movie so that it was more
appealing to the general audiences that
would be watching it this worked as well
with it being a big box office success
though copas made it clearly things says
other ways to experience the movie in
total you've got four different versions
of the film out in the wild and if this
is your first time jumping into it I'd
honestly go with a theatrical that's the
more straightforward and right to the
point type of film but if you already
love it then you have to check out the
extended versions the first of these is
the assembly car which comes in at
almost 5 hours that includes everything
they shot and is basically the version
cober put together before going at it
with the editing knife the third version
came out in 2001 which was titled Redux
and it was hit with a lot of backlash in
the same way that it's Redux sorry redo
of Godfather 3 Koda was to the
additional scenes had Kilgore helping a
wounded child before his surfboard was
stolen by Willard who then chased him in
a helicopter asking for a back we also
had the playmate scene in Willard being
imprison in the Box whilst Curt read him
an excert from Time Magazine talking
about the war certain elements of this
remained in the latter version but it
was a far more expensive version of the
movie often criticized as being blooded
and slow it was said to make the movie
worse and thus the Final Cut was crafted
dropping in 2019 this also had some of
those additional scenes that we'll talk
about in just a bit including the French
Plantation however a lot of the seen Sao
criticism were C leading to a vision
that c players said he's most proud of
now this includes writing something that
he saw as somewhat of a regret during
the production jav kital was actually
originally in the part of Willard but
couf fired him one week into production
we bit the bullet and uh and did you
know a very very unpleasant thing which
is uh replace an actor although we'll
never know the full extent of what
happened it said Copler didn't like his
interpretation and onset demeanor he
said he was imp patient and wanted
Willer to be more of a passive onlooker
according to the rumors right and I'm
not I'm not making this up kitel had
narrow eyes or aen had bigger ones which
helped to add into the naivity the
character was supposed to feel according
to variety kitel left the movie because
of a contract dispute and due to the
fact that things halted for three months
to make way for Brando cobbler of course
worked with him and Robert Duval on the
guarda and in some ways he got Sheen
from the production of that too although
Sheen never got the pot of Michael he
did audition for it and then he ended up
being brought in as the replacement
however in the Final Cut You Can
apparently see kite tell in the film at
one point from his one week of filming
at the beginning of the movie we see a
shut of the boat taking off from the
dark with kital sitting at the front of
it man's back we are so back now but it
kind of shows that cobbler may not be
proud with how he fully handled the
situation to be fair though he had a
hell of a lot on his play which as
mentioned is documented in hearts of
Darkness filmed by cess wife Elena she
took a lot of their private
conversations which were said to have
been done under the pretense of them
being for her diary like the characters
she said they went through the Journey
between sanity and insanity and he
commanded a crew of over 600 people when
you include set Builders and crew
nowadays you just CGI most of it but
these guys had to build sets that were
often destroyed by the weather with them
getting hit by extreme typhoons started
out just it was raining a lot and after
a while we realized it was knocking out
centers of civilizations and rivers were
over running
and I realized that certain sets had
been destroyed in order to rebuild the
sets Francis has closed down the
production for 2 months on top of this
there was also the political climate in
the country Philippine generals were
sent in every day to oversee things and
Pilots were called into fighting the
conflict which led to tens of thousands
of dollars being wasted in expensive
shots due to the story's order to kill
one of their own the US military refused
to give Copler any equipment and thus it
was borrowed from the local Army however
the military kept worrying that the
rebels attack the helicopters leading to
there being a ton of tension when
filming the movie on top of this they
also route the ending with the original
pitch being that kurts and Willard would
fight alongside each other against the
vi Kong the US helicopters would then
come in and they'd refuse to give up the
land that they fought for and then
they'd Gunn down the helicopters kopa
always knew that he wanted to rewrite
the ending and lean into Heart of
Darkness along with what he himself
experienced when he was making the movie
he found it so difficult to lock down
the ending but the delays caused by the
T typhoon gave them two months to work
on it in the end they managed to pull
things together and the film stances a
testament to their work and also what
soldiers likely went
through that's my opinion now as for the
movie itself we begin with a shut of the
Jungle which is then blanketed in Napal
this instantly sets the tone for the
film with the nature of the Jungle being
destroyed by man's fire and vengance
however I feel this has a deeper layer
to it with the hell Illusions also being
cemented by this shot hell is of course
thought to be made of burning fires that
cover the entire landscape and
symbolically fire appears throughout the
film this is also matched up with a
smoke too which appears frequently
during the movie whether it's the
colorful gas grenades Willard's head
emerging or just the smoke coming from
the Flames it appears throughout the
film both beautiful and deadly far is
what we think of when we think of the
apocalypse and the apocalypse itself is
seen as being the end this is why the
End by The Doors perfectly fits the tone
of this shot and let us know what kind
of Journey we're in for now along with
the journey through the circles of hell
I also feel the film itself is one of
getting to the depths of what it means
to be human huge shout out to the
channel what it all meant for bringing
up the fact that the movie is based on
hot of darkness and the journey itself
is about traveling into man's heart of
darkness they pointed out that the
rivers themselves could metaphorically
be seen as veins with the pit stops
along the way being what clogs up the
arteries this stops the heart which is
at the center of it all and it's all
about just reaching that heart of
Darkness it's also important to bear in
mind that this movie is very much about
Duality and that K is someone who's a
dark mirror of Willard Willard has two
PS that he can walk in the film with him
either joining CTS and leading his clan
or going off and becoming something else
in the end CTS actually wants him to
kill him because this will then allow
him to take over his place this is why
he emerges to the tribe all before him
at the end because this was all part of
the big plan at least that's how I take
it anyway and the idea of Duality with a
man is played upon early in the the film
when we hear kman laying out the two
sides of man before playing this clip
though listen now for the references to
Duality and the notion that there's
conflict within one's heart because
there's a conflict in every human heart
between good and evil between the
rational and the irrational every man
has got a Breaking Point good does not
always Triumph sometimes Dark Side
overcomes what Lincoln called the better
angels of our nature these references
they could in bad light and dark they're
encompassed perfectly in both Kurt and
Willard who are opposite sides of the
same coin Kurt is even shot mainly in
darkness where as will it is in again
painting out these two sides of Shadow
and light it makes for what's two
brilliantly complicated characters and
it all stems out from these opening
moments now the opening shot was almost
never in the film with Copa pulling the
footage out the trash during the editing
process this was actually a discarded
trim of the Village attack but cobbler
realized that when accompanied by the
end it made for something both beautiful
and deadly now superimposed over the top
of this we get Willard who's then
further joined by the spinning fan on
the ceiling the marrying of these images
may seem odd but I feel like the upside
down aesthetic shows where Willard's at
mentally the world has been flipped on
its head and we learned that Willard's
suffering from PTSD the fan resembles
the blades of a helicopter and even
though he's out the war he's never truly
left
it now this beginning is important
because will is a representation of a
post-war Soldier who's still feeling the
after effects of it memories litter his
mind and he's unable to truly let go we
hear how when he was in N he wanted to
be back home with his wife raising her
family but when he was back home he
wanted to be here it shows how Walken
create an addiction because there's no
real rules and there might be some
personalities that just long for this
Primal State now Madness leaps off the
screen with Martin's performance and the
scene was actually shot on his 36
birthday man was Mortal drunk and all
the stuff here including the mirror
punch was performed by him just messing
about on set that opening sequence was
shot on my 36th birthday and I was so
drunk I couldn't stand up
frankly him cutting his hand was real
and they ended up even including a line
about it in the script later on when he
meets Coran notice that you have a bad
hand there are you wounded that's a
little fishing accident on RNR shows
that he seems stable but he obviously
can't show what he's dealing with
mentally so intoxicated I didn't realize
how close to the mirror I was so when I
struck it I ended up catching my thumb
in the mirror and split it open a
[Music]
bit now unfortunately Sheen ended up
suffering a heart attack during the
filming which further Delights shooting
saying it was just heat stroke this was
used as the excuse so that the investors
wouldn't worry about further funding a
film that was massively over budget
either way this scene really speaks to
the madness and we get shots into L over
the top of where Willets wearing the mud
mask that he has when killing KS now
I've really thought on this for a while
and again I think it ties in the whole
idea of how Willards trapped in hell you
could really watch this film on a loop
and this could be him Awakening carrying
PTSD after just finishing the mission to
kill C he has memories of it that litter
his mind but he's then pulled out of it
and sent on that mission which then
leads to him being back in the room
where he has PTSD once more it's a big
Theory time the time it's just a big
Theory time probably not real but the
music saying this is the end that could
represent him having already finished
the mission but he's living in his own
personal hell of doing this journey over
and over I wanted a
mission and for my sins they gave me one
sure it's probably a reach but I love
the way the film can make you imagine
these scenarios and seed on a deeper
level either way he's awoken by soldiers
dragged out of bed and forced to show
before being brought before kman and
Lucas fur's idea of Duality unmatched in
these two soldiers that pick up him and
also Corman and Lucas along with them is
a man named Jerry who stays silent for
the entire thing except for this one
line that just stands out
terminate with extreme prejudice now
according Tob trivia this line was first
popularized in a 1969 New York Times
article about a murder known as the
Green Beret case a viames asset was
accused of being a double hent and he
was tortured and killed under the
direction of CIA officials they told the
officers to terminate with extreme
prejudice and eventually all were put on
trial for his murder CT is too accused
of murdering several alleged double
agents and it kind of ties this all in
with the real life event Now Jerry is
kind of a mysterious character with him
somewhat representing a devil in his
shirt that commands the grunts what to
do all he does is issue The Kill Order
and he's quite Sinister sitting there
just waiting and watching to me he shows
who's really in charge and that the hups
will happily kill their own if they
question their Authority now they're
having to kill their own because he
stands up to what they represent and
it's a really complex idea to have US
troops killing US troops the first shot
we get of kurts he's in his military
uniform which is actually pulled from
Reflections in a golden eye this is a
film that cober worked on and there made
Curt at the end seem like a shadow of
his former self heading out we hear as
Willard is happily killed in the past
but with this being an American Soldier
it strikes a bit turmoil within him in
many ways this man reflects himself and
what could happen if his own Madness
takes control now on the boat we meet a
young Lawrence Fishburn who was only 14
at the time of filming lying about his
age he managed to get on the cast and
gave a theory about what his character
meant I think what it was that was me
that was clean was just that I was a kid
I mean it's
about the kids that were over there who
didn't know anything about anything just
kind of kind of snatched up and used his
Cannon f for this war now J toos this
with how the actor saw War when he was
14 thing's really fun I mean a war is
fun you can do anything you want to
that's why Vietnam must have been so
much fun really shows how kids were just
kind of brought into it with no idea
what they were really doing and he
represents the lie that's been sold to
them his character's name is clean and
along with him we meet chef is also
getting a celebrity Surfer and Lance
lastly is Chief and it's at this point
that they really leading into the
voiceover as well which I don't actually
think is delivered by mon Sheen now it's
difficult to tell at what bits this
happened but due to how long the edit
took there were a lot of actors that
moved on while working on it coule
realized he'd need Sheen to provide
voiceovers but he was UN able to perform
them at the time due to being bucked on
other things thus they called in Sheen's
brother Joz who actually sounded
identical to M esz was also used during
some of the standing shots while marttin
recovered from his heart attack with
some of the the back shorts belonging to
him anyway after the piece is destroyed
by The Village we get a little Cameo
from Copa himself don't look at the
camera go look at the camera just go by
like you're fighting like you're
fighting go look at the camera this
shows us another aspect of war and how
reporting can be used during a conflict
often this can be propaganda but Vietnam
and more modern Wars have shown the
reality of it during the second world
war a lot of things were manipulated and
glorified but modern Wars documented the
darker side to it I know it's all still
very manufactured but yeah that there is
definitely this this on the ground thing
that this new age reporting allowed to
happen now here it shows how
manufactured moments like this are with
Copler instructing him to look like he's
fighting when he isn't at this point
we're introduced to a hell of a big
scene stealer in Robert deval's killgore
Now kill Gore not that subtle of a name
and originally he was going to be called
colonel connage in the end I'm glad they
changed it but this name represents the
kind of person he is coming down in a
chopper we can read on the front that
the tagline for this is Death from Above
smoke ballows out of it almost like it's
hell inpired and we watch as he calmly
walks through the Carnage throwing Death
Cards on the bodies of women and kids
this shows how little he cares about the
fight to him this is like a game with
war being something he loves because
they always win due to their Advanced
artillery they can easy wipe out and
destroy those that live here which is
showcased in the home being bulldozed as
Willard gets to the beach Kore barely
even bothers to abolute Willard and this
shows how he really views the war
however we see with Lance that he does
this prominently and this shows where
his true interests lie man is actually
obsessed with surfing and this
represents a lot of things with him at
one point he says that he doesn't want
to advance because he knows it's going
to cost loads of lives but upon hearing
that it could be a good place to serve
he throws everything he has it is this
is because he'll do anything to make
Vietnam like home which is exemplified
in the parties and Lifestyles that they
have really though they're just fooling
themselves and it's not something
they're going to be able to return to I
think the reason that he loves the smell
of napom I love the smell of napom in
the morning it's not because it's just a
cool catchphrase but it's also because
of what napom represents smells
like victory for him it's an unbeatable
weapon that clears out an area and this
allows him to go in and then turn it
into America at this point he'll be able
to Surf again and get the feeling of
home that's being Stripped Away From Him
Now this idea of him putting home above
all else is seen when he goes to a
wounded VC fighter on the ground we see
a man holding in his intestines through
using an enamal pot which is apparently
something that happened in real life
journalist Philip Jones Griffith said a
soldier offed in water after realizing
how honorable it was to keep fighting
while he was mortally wounded here Kil
goor goes to do the same thing but he's
distracted by the fact that Lance has
arrived now in both real life in the
movie the line was any soldier who can
fight for 3 days with his inside Z can
drink from my canteen anytime here
though we get an idea of how little he
actually cares as when Lance arrives he
just takes away the water and goes over
the thing that he really cares
about a now this is actually a term used
in surfing with it meaning he stands
right foot forward inste the left now we
also get further religious imagery with
the church and then a sermon being
carried out a glow is said to emate from
Kilgore and we also see his almost
Heavenly lights eminate from Willet
sitting playing his guitar around the
the campfire it's clear that they're
desperate to make things like home now
if you like bringing the classics home
then definitely check out our partner
Arrow video who sell lots of Blu-rays in
4k's folder films they've got a massive
back catalog with a whole host of movies
and are having a big sale for December
right now on top of that if you use our
Link in the description and type out the
code heavy spoilers you'll get an extra
10% off it really helps us out and yeah
go check them out cuz they've got so
many good movies on the site That's
Heavy spoilers remember that code for
temp % off every time you ever buy from
Arrow now it's at this point that KGO
he's the good peaks of where the vi Kong
are heavily located and he decides to go
full steam ahead into it again tying
back to that weak salute to Willard it
shows he doesn't really care about
military operations what he's interested
in is gaining grounds to carry out his
Hobby and we watch as they then fly out
seven we've got it
spotted now you may recognize my man
from another really famous Vietnam film
which is Full Metal Jacket all
completely stole the show in there and
it was so cool seeing him pop up here
too anyway from here we get one of the
most iconic scenes in film history with
a helicopters flying out to the right of
the
[Music]
Valkyries this is actually meant to be
ironic as in the original Opera that it
was used in the Valkyries are defeated
after arriving at what they thought
would be be an easy win America would of
course end up losing the war and this is
why this song was selected here a huge
shout outs to robis analysis on the film
which goes over what this thematically
could mean and I definitely recommend
you check out his full 40-minute
breakdown of the piece after this I
obviously can't touch on at all but he
brought up how the right of the
Valkyries was also based on the Vikings
who believe that if you died bravely in
battle you'd get into Valhalla these
Legends were used to fool soldiers in
adjoining these quests and fighting in
battles that would potentially lead to
their deaths now the Valkyries are also
in creatures with a helicopters two
riding into battle through the air like
the song's namesake the song is of
course also used to intimidate and we
see the schoolyard sent into Panic
before the helicopters rain down most of
the people CAU in the attack they seem
like they're civilians and it shows how
terrifying these skirmishes could be the
soldiers don't appear to panic though
and to them this is just another day to
try and get some ground now Rob pointed
out a further illusion to religion with
a wounded soldier on the ground
desperately praying for God
help God of course isn't come and Rob
pointed out how this could be a comment
on how valhall and the Valkyries would
never arrive even though the Vikings
believe they would now though the
soldiers have the advantage we also see
the danger they're in with the gorillas
throwing grenades into the chopper and
blowing some of them up you really think
this would bother kill goal but instead
all he cares about the surf what do you
think wow it's really exciting man oh no
no way this is the war to him and we see
as he lands on the ground with the gas
grenades like the LZ the colors here
really add to the trippiness of the Shar
with purple also potentially being used
to Common on Purple Haze that might be a
reach but it adds to the hypnotic side
of everything going on purple's actually
used prominently in the film and outside
of this it always signals death in The
Godfather Coba had orange appear just
before a character was killed whereas
here purple signifies that purple smoke
can be seen around when a character on
the boat dies foreshadowing that they're
just about to lose someone now even with
the battle still in full effect we see
his kilgor allowed his soldiers to serve
because that's where his Focus lies
these are people that he could easily
have helping him out but he sees that is
the purpose with the battle being
background noise now all of this was
such an iconic scene that it's even been
referenced in other films Back to the
Future 2 had a poster that said surf
Vietnam which was a little Easter R
calling back to this Kilgore also uses
the coign big Juke 6 which in itself is
homar to a very famous surfer that is
Juke Hoku who was a legendary Hawaiian
Surfer that brought the sports to the
masses after popularizing it during the
20s anyway the Napal strikes called in
and we get a slightly different angle of
that opening shot again this could add
to the theory that it's all a big time
Loop and Willard's remembering this
before being brought back into it
realizing the insanity of the situation
Willard and Lance fle at the boat and we
get the scene where Willard steals the
surfboard that debuted in Redux hearing
kilo's voice over the speakers it shows
his obsession and how far he'll go for
the surf not hurt or H just give me back
the board L either way it's also insane
to steal that during an active war zone
and it takes us into the next part of
our journey what I think works well with
the film as well is that it's almost
episodic in nature with each stop
bringing a new tone in style now to me
each Stop's important and it
demonstrates elements that could lead to
the downfall of humanity the First with
kill goes about killing and conquering
for selfish reasons and the second with
the USO tour that kind of showcases the
loss of decen morality the French stop
symbolizes people stubbornly refusing to
let go and the final stop showcases the
darkness within every man's heart and
the jungle itself comes with its own
dangers which we see when chef and will
had come across a tiger the behind the
scenes show that it had the pair scared
shitless when filming because they
basically just let it off the leash to
film that one scene all day the trainer
had been joking about how hungry it was
but still there weren't really any
safety measures is in place also to give
you an idea of how delayed the
production was as well the next scene on
the boat was shot a year after this was
filmed still though the intensity is
kept up with clean blasting away into
the jungle as they make their escape
this shows how trigger happy he is with
him later gunning down some civilians
that were just trying to protect the
puppy the puppy was purposely used
because it was a popular breed in
America that showed all the lives that
were needlessly ended to protect this
ideal it's one of the more memorable
parts of the movie with the Uso show
also being that as well now one of the
biggest questions I've seen about this
is why a show like this was so far into
the jungle as this is something that
would be extremely dangerous to hold
this was based on the time Playmate of
the a Joe Collins visited Vietnam and in
the end she was made an honorary GI
these Playmates all Wear Yellow clots
too and this symbolizes that they're
part of air cap here the main Playmates
played by Cynthia wood who in 1974 was
voted Playmate of the air whilst this
was being filmed interpretations of this
have said it's meant to symbolize the
madness in lure that one would have when
going further into the jungle John
millius stated that the girls were meant
to represent Sirens who inmat would lure
away Sailors and distract them from what
they were doing this would eventually
prove to be deadly with these women
making their minds Wonder these shows
were thought to boost morale for the men
but a lot of people have thought it just
demoralized the soldiers that's kind of
the interpretation that I have here too
with the troops rushing the stage and
trying to escape with the girls some
even hold for D life as the helicopter
takes off showing that they'd rather be
home than where they are now now we get
a beautiful Jer position as we hear
Willard talking about how the VC don't
get RNR and for them rice in a little
rat meat that's exactly what that is for
them there's only two ways home death a
victory with Willard realizing there's
no real way to win The Americans are
going against people who are built for
this land oras they just want to be back
home on top of this we also get a shot
where we can see them standing looking
through the fence showing that they're
all kind of distracted by what's on
display really levels the playing field
and shows everyone's on the same page
and just wanting to have the Comforts in
life instead of the war they've been
forced into now on the bo this siren
imagery is further alluded to with Chef
showing a center fold that he swears was
on stage we also heard a part of his
fantasy earlier on when he said he was
going through the jungle with Raquel
Welsh I'm walking through the jungle
Gathering
mangoes I meet Rael Welch women or
rather these irons are leading him along
with a frenchwoman later acting that way
too she appears through a veil luring
them away and distracting the soldiers
so the French can steal all their
supplies home and the Comforts of women
are what the group truly long for with
them desperately trying to claw their
back whilst retaining that Humanity
clean dances away to ion Get No
Satisfaction and we see Lance pulled
Along by the boat while he carelessly
knocks locals into the river this
somewhat lack of care and intoxication
is ironically pushed under them when
they shortly after encounter or some
other US troops on the river one of them
throws a grenade that sets fire to the
boat canvas showing how everyone's kind
of descended into their own base or
instincts alance represents his two and
we see how he joins him with clean
gunning down the civilians at this point
he started putting on face pain
indicating how he's getting further
intertwined with the jungle later on he
gets fully indoctrinated andurs
following with him wearing this while
becoming a member this civilian boat
also indicates one of the most important
sayings in the film let get up
never get out of the
boat absolutely godamn right getting off
the boat leads to all the civilians
being killed here and Willard guns down
the woman after we learned that she was
still alive Willard told them not to
stop and taking her to a hospital would
just slow them down every time they step
away from the boat something like this
happens which is coupled in the next
part at the doong bridge a far cry from
what's come before this shows the beauty
and Chaos that exists within wall This
was meant to show a twisted reality with
a soldiers reaching out the river almost
like Spirits trying to pull them
in the entire thing is is extremely
horrific and surreal with circus music
also being played amongst the chaos and
Carnage you wonder what they even
fighting for at this point and it's a
far cry from the structure and semblance
of Sanity that we saw down river now the
character roach here is based on Michael
herd's dispatches which was an account
of his time in Vietnam who worked on the
script for this film and interestingly
the scene's one of the more factual
Parts in it well it says there's no Co
here or really anyone in charge and it
shows what civilization descends into
without Law and Order now as they ride
away the bridge gets destroyed and this
in itself sort of like a mythological
punishment every day the soldiers are
ordered to rebuild it and every night it
ends up being blown up it further the
insanity of occupation and how cyclical
the conflict is with it being a constant
Loop of just rebuilding and destruction
now at this point we cut to the day and
we see the back of the boat which is
where we catch its name this says it's
called arabus which itself is named
after a Greek god arabus was the god of
Darkness with his realm being something
solds pass through on their way to Hades
can heat is also on the back to which
makes me think of that jqu song and look
mate I didn't say that'd all be good
Easter eggs mate I didn't promise you
that
however what's a nice little one is the
letters that the group get in the next
scene this includes clean with him
getting a tape recorded by Lawrence's
real life mother so bad you decid to
join he was not sure she you also see
how hypnotizing things are with Willard
reading about a soldier that went
looking for CTS only to be indoctrinated
by him he sent letters to his family
telling him to sell everything as he's
never coming back highlighting the
insanity that one could get from being
around him coupled with this we also get
a newspaper article which in itself is
talking about Charles Manson Manson made
his own cult too with this clearly being
a comment on what's happened with Kurt
now what this also helps to do is date
the events of the film as there's never
really a specific year given however
that happened in 1969 meaning that this
is likely taking place around the
autumn/winter at this point Lance Sparks
up the purple grenade which then leads
into our first B crew death that comes
in the form of Lance with his mother's
tape playing over the top as he lies
there like
bring your Hy home all in one piece CU
we love you very much it's so tragic and
it shows the true cost of war with it
being the young that are often put on
the front line as the ones to die from
here we then cut to what's an incredible
moment with the crew then traveling
under down B-52 just something about it
is so haunting and I feel like this was
chosen for a very specific reason a B-52
is a symbol of American might and it
being down here highlights the the fall
of
[Music]
power now from this point we travel into
the French part which is only available
in the extended versions this is really
a scene that I can see why they occur as
the total thing lasts for 24 minutes and
kind of bogs down the pacing there isn't
too much to take from it on the whole
but Copler talked about what it meant
during hearts of Darkness he stated
these people fought for the land much
like the Americans but they refuse to
let go even though they should just go
home when you back home to France I mean
this is our home Captain sooner or later
you going to get no this piece of Earth
we keep it we will never lose that never
one of the more poetic descriptions he
said is that it's like when a star dies
and its light's still out there
traveling sh can still see it but
technically it's not really there
anymore Willer describes they're still
hanging on like how America is but at
this moment America is just gripping
with more fingers they have dinners get
accordion players in and dress like
they're in Paris and though they fool
themselves they're clearly living a lie
why don't you Americans learn from us
from our mistakes this plea is almost
like a warning of what they're getting
themselves into and it sounds like he's
a trapped man in the end even if they
win this is the kind of fight they'll
have with it's sort of being an omen of
the future you are fighting for the
biggest nothing in the history here the
woman brings up the idea of Duality and
I said to
him they two of you but you are both
waking up from this hypnotic dream we
see his smoke surrounds them on the
river taking us into the mystical hot of
Darkness rain down by arrows we even see
a slance end up snapping one and
sticking it on his head these are just
sticks used for intimidation tactics
though but you can catch the purple
smoke behind the attacker who throws a
spear that kills Chief in the immediate
aftermath of his death we get a wide
shut of the bow which we can also see is
blanketed in the Smoke given a water
barrial by Lance this is a far cry from
the funeral they held for clean showing
how far he slipped traveling further up
the river we get more religious
iconography with crucifixes clearly
lining the shore this is when the movie
becomes its most trippy with a
soundscape altering our experience the
idea of Duality that comes into full
effect here with them traveling through
the two statue heads that showcase the
two SES arriving toward what a mass of
people on boats we see as Willards then
welcomed in now we can catch people
standing on stairs and the slim behind
Dennis Hopper's character the journalist
says all motto Apocalypse Now he said it
he said it now this title was con by
John milus who thought of it after
seeing the Nan and now tattoo that was
popular at the time this had a piece
symbol on it too but for the film logo
milus ended up altering this so it
instead looked like a B52 now though we
can't show this because of YouTube's
demonetization you can see around the
camp that there's bodies hanging up
according to the stories they were going
to pay for some real corpses to be used
but the authorities discovered they were
being being sold by a grave robber so
they just ask the extras on set at this
point we see the soldier Willard was
reading about before who seems as if
he's in a zombie-like state this guy is
played by Scott Glenn who I never even
recognized until doing this deep dive
Sheen also had his sons on set for this
to with both Charlie and amelo playing
extras in the movie unfortunately both
of their scenes occur but I did
appreciate seeing Glenn appear here
Willard's reaction has the character
staring at him and copela changed the
Hue of this moment so it had extra green
in it this included making his eyes seem
Greener too so it appeared like the
jungle had taken him in on the steps you
also get heads lining the location which
was accompanied by people being buried
into the set all day they were there in
the hot sun with smoke blowing on them
between takes they were covered with
umbrellas back on the boat we see his
Lancers starting to be hypnotized by the
location and Sam bottom sounds like he
had a crazy time filming it man did
numerous drugs while shooting it and I
think that does come across during his
performance now Chev is told to wait and
if he doesn't hear back then he's been
ordered to call in an air strike and
this takes us into all the Brando stuff
which sounds like it was wild behind the
scenes he said to have showed up on set
out of shape even though CTS was
supposed to be thin and wiry there cop
mainly shot the actor in Shadow to hide
what he could but tonally I think this
works brilliantly we never really get a
good look at kurts and he represents the
darkness within us all Sheen's also shot
heavily in Shadow too so you have these
two almost half faces that could perhaps
be a hole now Brando also refused to
read Heart of Darkness and he refused to
learn his lines this was the case on The
Godfather 2 and he actually had to have
them stuck on other actor chest so he
could read them during the scene they
were upside down though with brand
constantly leaning sideways in order to
try and read them now he argued with
Copa a lot and his first point of
contention was that an American wouldn't
be called Kurt so the character was then
renamed to Ley however after filming was
done he read the book and liked it the
demanding that his name should be
changed back all of the lines mentioned
lately were then redubbed to say kurts
including Harrison Fords hearts of
Darkness talks about what went on with
Brando and his process and we learn that
he improvised pretty much all of his
dialogue this include what's one of my
favorite lines in the film which ends
the first scene between him and will it
you're an Aaron
boy sent by gross looks collect a bill
now brand also performed a fully
improvised 20-minute speech which was
then cut down to 2 minutes in the end
hilariously he just ended it by saying I
can't think of any more dialogue today
which yeah professional until the end
now Willard's engaged and treated like
an animal before kurts goes to him on
the night rocking green and black face
paint I believe this is purposely mired
with the meaning behind why Lance did it
and it shows that he's almost like a god
of the Jungle dropping Chef's head onto
his lap this ends all the hope of him
calling in an air strike taken into a
temple we see a beam of light coming
down striking CTS potentially hinting at
his divinus and da like Persona we are
the
Hollowman now this point kurts reads
from the TS Elliot poem The Hollowman
this was inspired by Heart of Darkness
with the first line reading Mr CTS he
dead this line is left out when CTS
reads it however we do get a moment
calling back directly to its final line
is the way the world end look at
this we're in
man whimper and with a whimper the final
L of the po talks about the way the
world ends with it being a whimper which
is also how CTS goes out too the idea
for him being sacrificed was inspired by
the locals after Eleanor and Francis
watched a real life sacrifice the water
buffalo was also slaughtered for real in
the film with them capturing the
sacrifice being carried out by an
indigenous tribe this may help the think
that his demise should be handled like a
sacrifice with the tribe also somewhat
cons sending to it happening huge sh out
to use of the dark presence and R ping
out that we can also spot the book The
Golden bow in Curt's quarters this has
the high priest of the cult of Diana
whose job was to lead the cult and
protect Diana's sacred tree he was also
tasked with looking for his successor
who he was told could arrive at any time
this person would then kill him and
become him which explains his thinking
behind what happens in the end he is a
man who somewhat sees himself as
existing outside of time and even the
Roy XI wees has its bezels missing this
is because time zones aren't something
that's important to anym unless he just
has this very strip back watch now
Dennis hoer and Brando they didn't get
along on S with Marin apparently yelling
at him over a simple misunderstanding
from this point on BR refused to share
the set with him even in the scenes that
the pair were in together th when BR
does this you either love somebody or
you hate
him he's not actually there and you kind
of get the feeling that this was
actually how brand felted about him this
was shot in separate nights so the pair
didn't interact and Brando also spent
time on set dissing ber Reynolds this
was recorded in a tape behind the scenes
it's a long one but I'll play a little
excert from it I think it's B Reynolds
that's one of the reasons we're doing
don't say that name around me do you not
like him uh he is the epitome of
something that makes me want to throw up
he's a nice guy he is you want to come
no you don't I don't know why I hate him
no he is a nice guy is he can't be he's
he he's the epitome of everything that's
disgusting about the
thespian just hold he did you get that
idea I don't know him at all he worships
at the Temple of his own narcissism now
Reynolds was also apparently almost
casting The Godfather but Brando
threatened to quit if he ever got the
pot whatever you think of the actor
though you can't deny he gave an
unforgettable performance he's
completely mesmerizing in this with imp
perfectly capturing the insanity and
darkness of the situation Brandel
completely steals the movie and this is
actually aided by what they did with
will it B the voice over that that we
hear narrating things he doesn't
actually speak for the final 30 minutes
Willis last words spoken aloud are I'm a
soldier and it shows where his true
allegiances lie however I feel like he
steps away from this at the end and this
is why he puts his weapon down this
weapon is a curve blade which is also
similar to what's used in the sacrifice
but the Trib to follow him in doing this
too showing that the war may now be over
for them taking Lance I feel like
Willard goes off on his own path instead
of the two that have been chosen for him
rather than being an assassin or a
leader he'll be his own person and go
back home or at least that's how I take
it however I feel this is cemented by
this line they were going to make me a
major for this and I wasn't even in
their Army anymore which shows
that he's not really part of them
anymore his final Act is to turn off the
radio showing that he's no longer
listening to them now this shot is then
accompanied by a helicopter superimposed
over the location showing that they
they'd potentially come into bomb it all
however I feel this signifies the war
will never end and that the death and
horror are just going to continue
Forever
horor War is Everlasting because of the
darkness that exists within all hearts
and this is the true horror that we're
going to have to face the Vietnam War
wouldn't end with this Mission and the
horror that we've experienced will still
continue however Willard still carries
on the killing and we see him rise out
of the water almost like a baptism in
which his has been wiped away he's a new
person letting go of all of that and we
watches he sneaks into the temple and
kills him this sacrifice is mered with
the shots of the Caribou being killed
which symbolizes The Duality between
these two moments I find it a really
hard watch and there's no way you get
away with this scene in the US still
though it shows the brutality of war and
lets us fill in the blanks of what
happened with Kurt over the top of this
we hear the do sumping away and KP
actually went to the UCLA film school
with all of the band's members they
allowed him to use all their music for
the movie with the 5H hour assembly C
being scored entirely to that now in the
aftermath of his death Will finds Kurt's
writings which he starts to skim through
over the top of the typed out Pages we
sees written in red a terrifying message
that is Drop the Bomb exterminate them
all which is something I think can be
taken a number of different ways this is
a book that Willard carries out with him
and it could single that CTS realized he
and his tribe had reached the end of the
road they realized they were never going
to win and it was time to put down their
weapons and let the bomb wipe them out
however it could be his instructions to
the US military which will it may take
to show them in the end the words it's
judgment that defeats us that sticks out
to me showing that the US could drop
nukes but they refuse to do it it's
their judgment to try and be moral
during immoral times that means they
refuse to make the devastating choice
that will help them win the war again
it's purely my interpretation and I
think there's other ways that it can be
looked at twoo you could even see the
opening of the film being the outcome of
what happens here and if this is on a
loop then that explains what's going on
this could be why the images of Willard
and murder interlace with that and it
may spoil the ending in that very first
shot either way we close out the film
and feel the true impact of the
NeverEnding horror Curt's death means
nothing in the grand scheme of things
and it won't change the outcome of any
of the conflict it really ends things on
an nihilistic not and some the movie as
an incredible piece of film it really is
one of the greatest movies of all time
that was a nightmare both on and off the
screen when preparing this video I
watched this in a pitch black room with
just the movie to take me on its journey
and and it's one of the most immersive
experiences that I've ever had this was
astounding and it completely stands a
test of time and I can't praise the
movie highly enough now I hope you've
enjoyed our interpretation of it and
videos like this are all made by people
like you who've signed up to our
membership but just 99 cents a month
you'll get early access to videos and
help us keep going back through these
classic movie breakdowns if you want to
support us then please click the join
button but even if you don't have the
money then we'd also really appreciate
the thumbs up I had such a blast going
through this all and whether you agree
or disagree with our interpretations I'd
of course love to hear thoughts too
that's what I think a brilliant film
does and it can really be taken a number
of different ways so yeah drop your
thoughts Below in the comment section
and make sure you subscribe to keep up
with our classic movie breakdowns on
screen right now we've got one for The
Truman Show and the next series for
tackling is going to be back to the
future that will be coming out with Die
Hard in between so you've also got a
Christmas movie to watch over the
holidays huge thank you for sticking
with us this long I'll see you next time
much love
peace